hello everyone and welcome to the first
game of the match Wesley Seoul versus
Magnus Carlsen we are now in the losers
bracket as both of them lost in the
winners bracket of the chessable Masters
division one uh if you guys remember I
talked about how even if you lose a
match in the Winner's bracket you can
also bounce back from the loser's
bracket and find your way back into the
winners bracket but you have to play
very well and here Wesley and Magnus are
trying to eliminate each other to climb
back into the the Winner's bracket and
the difference is uh in the winners
bracket you get to play Four rapid games
before playing an Armageddon game but in
the losers losers bracket only two games
will be played and then if it's a draw
then we immediately go into Armageddon
and this is the first game of the Rapids
uh it's quite a quite a wild one Wesley
goes for a very early in the very very
uh crazy Pawn sacrifice and the game
features two really awesome pause the
video moments that were missed by both
players well at least one player Maybe
by both players but you guys will have a
chance to tackle those positions so
let's check it out it's Wesley with the
white pieces and he opens with that not
that with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to C5
Magnus of course goes for the Sicilian
Defense Knight to F3 we have knighted
the C6 and Bishop to B5 now you can be
pretty sure if you go E4 then magnets
will go for the Sicilian uh he just
prepared it so well for his last World
Series championship title or for rather
his two last World Series championship
title defenses uh that um I don't yeah I
like yeah okay look at this you might
not consider this a serious game because
it's an online rapid game uh but uh yeah
it's a it's an important event and of
course Magnus will go for for the main
stuff so okay Ponte E5 and we already
mentioned this uh so many times that you
guys of course know that you cannot win
the E5 Pawn so here just uh castles and
now Bishop to D6 as now the pawn is
vulnerable and here the standard way of
playing this is by playing C3 preparing
D4 you could also play D3 if you want to
play a really slow system
uh Bishop to see for his own where you
can play Knight to C3 basically any
movie is a move here uh but Wesley goes
for Pawn to D4 it's the move that I
decided to put in the thumbnail because
it's just so so wild it's like something
you would see in uh you know in in a
game from morphe Zera just uh giving up
a pawn straight up no no uh serious
compensation just uh getting uh crazy
playable possession so here uh well you
could play something like C captures on
the four and then C3 and then we go into
some uh funky lines because okay we
can't capture a further because the
bishop on D6 is hanging uh Magnus just
plays Knight captur Sandy for he says
thank you for for the pawn I don't want
any uh tricky business here so okay
Knight captures on D4 we have C capture
Sunday for Magnus does have a double c d
Pawn now but it's very well protected so
you don't really have to worry about
that we have C3 by Wesley and now Bishop
to C5 we have Pawn to B4 by Wesley and
Bishop to B6 and there is one game where
Bishop the BT was played but here Wesley
plays Pawn the A4 and it is now as of
move nine that we have a completely new
game so okay uh A5 is coming Magnus
prepares it with a A6 so now he can
bring the bishop back all the way to A7
push it back to B3 and now Knight to F6
we have Pawn to A5 Bishop to A7 and now
even Pawn to B5 was the really
uh going uh wild and uh on the queen
side pushing those pawns with eight
captures on B5 and now Knight the A3
preparing the capture back with the
Knight so he can go after that Bishop so
he is kind of playing against magnus's
Bishop pair for the moment that this
bishop is actually this bishop isn't
doing nothing and the trading Knight for
Bishop would be very nice but here
Magnus plays D captures on C3 Knight
captures on B5 and Bishop to C5 Magnus
not quite ready to part with his Bishop
Fair Bishop to G5 attacking the Knight
and here Magnus just castles you could
also go uh for something like uh Rook
captures on A5 winning that pawn right
away but Magnus is not worried he he he
can always uh capture it later so here
he castles and Wesley plays Knight
captures on C3 and now you have to be
careful now already Wesley is planning
to put the Knight on D5 and it would be
very dangerous as the Knight and F6
cannot move due to the pin so here Pawn
to H6 by Magnus Bishop captures an F6
Queen captures and the Wesley does win
his D5 Square so the Knight is on D5 and
the magnets will have to waste quite a
few Moves In order to get rid of it at
least three something like D6 Bishop P6
and Bishop captures but then also you
have to give up the bishop here then
maybe Pawn captures then maybe the
bishop comes alive uh it's a it's a very
very tricky position because there's no
actual compensation for the pawn that
Wesley sacrificed uh but you know you
still you still have to be very careful
so Queen back to d8 uh and now Queen to
D2 Magnus just continues development uh
West continues development uh Pawn to D6
now preparing to develop the bishop and
Rook F to B1 Wesley stops this and now
you can see that uh it's not that easy
to develop the bishop cannot move the
pawn on B7 would hang so Magnus plays
Rook the A7 you could also consider Rook
the B8 but it just looks weird if some
A6 action becomes possible so Magnus
first place Rook to A7 and it's not for
the sole purpose of defending the pawn
on B7 as Magnus wants to develop the
bishop move the queen he also wants to
double up Rooks on the a file so that's
why rooked A7 is so strong uh King to H1
by Wesley getting off of this diagonal
and now Bishop to E6 with Bishop to C4
and now Queen to H4 bringing the queen
into the attack putting pressure on the
F2 Pawn so Wesley defends at Pawn to F3
you could also consider Pawn to F4 I
obviously decides to go F3 and now Rook
F the A8 by Magnus doubling up here
going after the A5 Pawn Rook to A2 and
now Queen back to d8 Bringing another
attacker to the A5 pawn and now you
cannot continue defending the pawn play
something like Rook to B5 it seems like
it's an okay move but you can just play
Bishop D4 not allow any tricks and then
the next movie we're gonna play Bishop
to D7 kick away the rook and then win
the pawn so Wesley knows that there's no
saving that pawn he plays Spawn to H3
uh but now you can see that there might
be uh some issues here uh the bishop
covers G1 so the king can never come to
G1 this bishop targets H3 so if if the
queen comes to H4 and you somehow
sacrifice this bishop with Bishop
captures on H3 could get very nasty so
here we have uh after H3 just root
captures an A5 Magnus wins uh the pawn
here Rook captures on B5 B7 we have Rook
captures an A2 Bishop captures on A2 and
now uh Queen to H4 Magnus goes for this
uh very very tricky move and now uh I've
already mentioned it but it's still
tricky here Wesley played King to H2 of
course he doesn't want to allow some
tricky Bishop captures an H3 action uh
he played King to H2 but now it's still
completely lost but it's not easy to see
why feel free to pause the video and win
the game for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting what
uh both Magnus and Wesley could not and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Bishop to F2 that's the
move that wins the game and now you're
probably wondering why is this the move
that wins the game well what do you play
with white is there a movie you can play
you can't really move the bishop you're
gonna allow Rook day one and some like
Bishop Bishop to G3 Checkmate uh so
obviously moving the bishop is not an
option you could you could play
something like Knight to E7 check and
then re-maneuver the Knight to F5 but
okay let's try this King to H7 Knights
to F5 and what now Bishop captures
Knight Pawn captures bishop and now Rook
captures an A2 that's the only one of
the points and now after Queen captures
there's this beautiful queen to F4 check
look at this queen to F4 Queen to C1
Queen to G1 Spectacular Now you you have
no way of defending this game to H1
Queen to C1 checking H2 and now Queen to
G1 will be Checkmate all made possible
as the bishop covers both G3 and G1 and
aside from this if you try some other
moves after this bishop to have to move
like I said you could consider something
like Rook to beat you so uh Rook
captures an 80 will never be an option
now but uh now you play Queen to G3 uh
with check King to H1 and now Bishop D4
you attack the rook and that's pretty
much it uh black has to give up the
record you play Bishop to C2 and now
comes the move that we discussed Bishop
captures an H3 G captures and queen to
G1 Checkmate or any of the other lines
where black is also completely winning
so that was in the position Magnus
however missed it he played King to H7
and now we have Rook the B2 now
obviously realizes okay I can't really
allow that a real characters on uh on A2
in all of these lines we have rooked the
A3 by Magnus and now Rook the B3
offering a rook trade and now Magnus
goes back Rook to A7 which is uh which
is kind of a shame uh he could have gone
from Bishop captures on H3 here it's
very deadly because after G characters
on H3 there's again this bishop to F2
move and now how do you defend Checkmate
it's just such a such a powerful move in
all the lines you have to go for a nice
king walk King to G2 Queen G3 checking
to F1 You're Gonna Play Queen to G1
check and now King the E2 and now look
at this hypothetical position uh feel
free to pause the video once again and
win the game uh for for black uh
hypothetically win it well I'll give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
not an easy move to find and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Bishop to E1 absolutely phenomenal
move because now you have nothing to do
to to play if Queen captures Bishop then
you allow Rook captures uh Bishop with
check and then the queen hangs and if
you don't play that you just allow Queen
to have to check even if play some like
Queen to beat you there's still Rook
captures on A2 and after Queen captures
just uh Queen to have to checking to D1
and queen captures on A2 uh into the
game you are you're up a full Queen so
uh Magnus misses that as well he goes
real back to A7 he's just concentrating
not the blunder the game away he's up a
pawn and you know he he wants to play an
end game Rook to B1 was played with
Bishop to F2 finally he plays it but now
Rook to F1 Wesley finds a very nice
defense against this bishop G3 check
King to H1 now Bishop to F4 we have
Queen to F2 offering a queen trade and
now Magnus goes for it Queen captures
actual characters and Bishop captures on
D5 we have e captures on D5 and now
Bishop to G3 it's uh and then game now
of opposite color Bishops but the Rooks
are still in the game so it's not that
easy for Wesley to draw this even though
uh he he's uh down a pawn uh with Bishop
to B1 with check G6 and only now Rook to
A2 offering a rook trade uh Magnus of
course declines if he Trace Rooks then
it's a draw uh Wesley tries again and
now Rook the B7 with Bishop to A2 and
now Pawn to H5 and now okay Magnus does
that with perfect uh play uh this is
probably a win uh but it will it's not
gonna be easy uh King to G1 we have King
to H6 King to F1 and now King to G5 both
players trying to activate their kings
as much as possible King to E2 and now
Pawn to F5 with King to D3 now Rook to
A7 Bishop to C4 getting the bishop out
of any potential harm Rook the A3 with
check Rook the C3 and Rook to A1 with
repeats Rook does C2 and now King the F4
we have rooked the E2 and now Rook the
A3 with check with King back to C2 now
comes Ponte E4 of course you have to try
uh pushing otherwise you know you have
you don't have additional resources to
try and win the game f captures F
captures in the bishop to B5 Wesley just
waiting to see what happens Rook day 5
attacks the bishop Bishop back to C6 and
now Pawn to G5 we have King to C3 and
now King to E5 we have Rook to B2 and we
have rooked the C5 with check here
um uh Rook the B2 is a very tricky move
by Wesley because Magnus could also
consider root captures on D5 he's
already up a pawn so he might be willing
to give up The Rook for this pawn and
the bishop there that way okay he's
gonna be down the exchange but he will
have to connect the uh pass Pawns in the
center but this tricky Rook to beat you
move by Wesley prevents exactly that
because now if you trade Wesley has Rook
B5 sorry uh Rook to B5 check and he's
also going to pick up the G5 pawn and
then that's not gonna be enough to win
the game only three points now against
two uh being down the exchange so Rook
the C5 check by Magnus we have King to
D2 and now Bishop to F4 with
H4 uh we have Rook day two Wesley has to
win and see what happens Rook to C1 and
now Rook the B2 with Bishop to G3 Magnus
being very sneaky about it he's trying
to get Rook D1 uh check into the game
soaking the E3 and now still Rook the E1
check with um
uh uh Rook D do you blocking this check
now Bishop to F4 with check King to F2
and now Rook the A1 and here Magnus had
a fairly sufficient time he had some two
minutes on the clock but Wesley was down
to some 10 seconds so he was really
playing an increment uh Rook the B2 was
played Rook to A3 and now King to E2
Bishop to E3 by Magnus and now Rook to
B8 just waiting for Magnus to try and
push for the win and then maybe make a
mistake but he doesn't Bishop to C5
we've Rook back to beat you and now Rook
the A1 going for Rook to G1 and the
Wesley played King to D2 and now Rook
the G1 and he was in this position on
move 66 that Wesley Soul resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here the problem is uh the Rook covers
all of these squares and the bishop and
pawn cover all of these squares so if
you know if you want to stop Rook
captures on G2 which would give black
too much material advantage the only
Square for your king is King to C3 but
that of course is impossible because of
Bishop D4 check winning The Rook so
that's why Wesley resigned so it's a
really really uh weird game where Wesley
went for this immediate the D4 I mean uh
that's a movie you simply don't expect
here you have C4 and E uh C5 and E5
guarding the D4 square and you know that
D4 is impossible but that's exactly the
move that Wesley tried against Magnus so
he really he really pushed it and uh you
know it's definitely in the style of the
of the enes meddino the rosalimo attack
is you know reminiscent of something
maybe Rashid nej Medina would play but
it didn't work um against Magnus he just
uh kept hogging that extra pawn and in
the end he was able to trade on in the
end game and it just mattered and even
even though he had a win a couple of
times so you know with tactical
resources he knew that if he you know
plays it well that that pawn up will be
um enough the the to win a game and uh
well he just didn't want to invest any
any time in trying to crack that
position but of course you guys solved
uh maybe one but probably both of them
so yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you have any of your
favorite games from the chessboard
Masters do use hashtag suggestion and I
will go over them uh I would like to
thank Stephen Cornell uh Revolution
reptiles YouTube Eric Holtman even
Sterling and Philip Kessler tax Guru for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day